I feel like it's a very universal story
about a young woman coming of age
that's Jada pinkett-smith at the
premiere of her new movie Halle the film
follows a young girl who's navigating
the conflicting worlds of her
traditional Muslim household and her
modern high school I am of two parts
divided
stranger Halle and family
as women we all can understand the
struggle of just trying to
self-actualize so whether it's you know
trying to individualize ourselves from
our mothers identity or what we think
our fathers want us to be our culture
society you know just trying to find our
way and find our own self actualizing a
way to find our own autonomy and so
that's what really drew me to the idea
of the the movie and showed about the
little bit my mother never said that
under the same roof
[Music]
one-eye rushes forward fearlessly
because she's Muslim and because she's
from Pakistan really doesn't make her
journey that much different then my
journey is an african-american woman or
the journey of an asian-american woman
or a Native American woman we all kind
of struggle with the same things they
might just wear a different face Paula's
story is a prime example some of the
powerful conversations we've seen on
Jada's famous read.table talk so what
would the host asked if hala came to the
table she kind of found her own healing
at the end of the movie which is what
makes it so beautiful she found a way to
find her own autonomy while also holding
on to her faith and her culture right so
I would probably talk in detail about
how she did that and what were the
internal changes that she made or things
that she discovered that gave her more
strength to individualize in the way
that she has and speaking of read.table
talk on Monday Jada had an emotional
interview with Robin Crawford who shared
some raw revelations about a
relationship with the late Whitney
Houston she's probably the only person
that I've met that there are other
people as well but to sit down and have
that kind of conversation around an
experience of that kind and Robin is so
warm and compassionate so she was so
patient with me so it wasn't like I
really felt like I was sitting down with
a girlfriend you know and just kicking
it and we were just talking about our
experiences around this specific topic
so it was us healing for me
to be able to have that kind of
interaction the actress also revealed
her next big guest on the Facebook watch
show well my next big guest is tip okay
two guys coming to the table yes indeed
yeah tip and tiny and of course he's
going to address the controversy that
has been swirling and we just shot that
today and then he and tiny sit down and
talk about how they survived in regards
to their marriage and so that'll be next
Monday up next for Jada she's set to
star in the matrix for her hubby Will
Smith has openly admitted he regrets
turning down the role of neo played by
Keanu Reeves so does this mean Jada is
putting a good word in for her man to
find a role in the upcoming sequel no I
don't need to put in a good word for
Will Smith
[Laughter]